[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
one year ago today china told the world
health organization about the
coronavirus for the first time
the search for a vaccine started soon
after but there is serious concern that
poorer countries are being left behind
in the search for global immunity
thousands of volunteers from low-income
countries in africa took part in
clinical trials of
the new vaccines in spite of that new
research indicates wealthy countries
with just 14 percent of the world's
population
have bought more than half of the doses
of leading vaccines
deborah patta is in south africa looking
at what the consequences could be
if vaccines are not distributed
equitably
a shot in the arm in a small stuffy room
in the township of soweto
[Music]
it may not look like much but dimakatsu
canadi believes this is her
only opportunity to protect herself
against
covert 19 for the foreseeable future so
i felt this is a good chance for me
because
i'm not working and it's a chance for me
so let me go for it so this was your
best chance of getting a vaccine
it was her instincts are not far off
canadian is participating in one of four
vaccine trials underway in south africa
but despite being at the forefront of
vaccine research on this continent
this country like so many other african
nations
might have to wait until 2023
before everyone has been immunized what
we are headed for right now is a
scenario where
the frontline healthcare workers in
ethiopia will still be waiting to be
vaccinated even after all the
20 year olds in the u.s have been
vaccinated and that is an unacceptable
scenario
andrea taylor is duke university's lead
researcher into global vaccine
distribution
she tells us that the delay in
vaccinating poorer countries
will have devastating consequences for
the global economy
costing wealthy nations around 120
billion dollars nobody is safe
until everyone is safe there's also
a very real risk that if the pandemic is
allowed to continue raging
in poorer countries well high-income
countries are protected
it can continue to mutate and spread and
there's a chance that we could end up
then with a strain
that our current vaccine candidates
don't cover
around 100 nations have joined an
initiative to help provide
fair access to vaccines but it's so far
falling well short of demand
and once the vaccine finally reaches
low-income nations
there is another major roadblock ahead
distribution just ask any un health
worker about the logistical nightmare
of transporting vaccines to remote areas
using bikes in south sudan on foot in
nepal
by donkey and yemen or over water to
far-flung villages in the democratic
republic of congo
the fisa vaccine already being
distributed in the u.s
needs to be stored at ultra freezing
temperatures
a problem for places with poor or
non-existent electrical grids
professor shabir mahdi heads up the
oxford astrazeneca trials in south
africa
it's a front runner for wide
distribution here
because it's cheaper than the other
leading candidates and only requires
normal refrigeration he says the covert
vaccine will have to be easily
accessible
so that people don't have to travel
miles
to get that life-saving shot we need to
ensure that the
program itself is extremely friendly and
inviting for people to come forward
because the last thing that we're
wanting to do is add fuel
to the anti-vaccine lobby in terms
of why people shouldn't be vaccinated
that's what we want him to avoid
this may be a new pandemic but it comes
with age-old problems of inequality
as developing nations prepare for the
mammoth task
of vaccinating hundreds of thousands of
people
in remote corners of the globe for cbs
this morning deborah patter
alexandra township south africa
some consequential reporting there from
deborah and it's something when i was a
foreign correspondent in africa
you talk about aids and malaria under
the best of conditions these countries
are struggling
you'd factor in covet 19 and the fact
that 20 year olds here in the u.s will
be vaccinated before essential workers
in ethiopia
is remarkable just watching that puts
our concerns and complaints in
perspective doesn't it
and so many immigrants in this country
have family overseas in developing
country i worry about
my grandmother in the dominican republic
who's 86 years old she's probably not
going to get this for years